so hi everyone my name is Luke I'm a PhD
student at the University of Leuven
Belgium and I'm going to talk about a
project that started around three years
ago at MIT called Bonnie good yep so
this is my phone that I carry with me
everyday in my pocket and I take it when
I when when I wake up I have with me in
my pocket every day every every places I
go and if you think a bit about it this
far not a bit a lot about my life a lot
about my behaviors he knows all the
places I go you know that I went to
London diced in Brussels all the time
you know the people i call you know
people that i sent text you for how long
I call people in other lot about my life
and there's someone else who knows all
the same information it's my mobile
phone provider and mobile phone
providers the store also made a data
about your interactions when you call
someone they stored at the fact that you
call someone from this cell tower during
use this number of time entered recorded
for business purposes during at least
one year so research that I've been
working with that sort of data which is
very very fine-grained data and when you
think about mobile phone metadata for
millions of people in the country you
can learn a lot about people behavior
supportin researchers have been able to
attract epidemics such as malaria or
dang by using people mobility with the
phone as a proxy for the human mobility
in the world country other people have
been trying to predict people gender age
or socioeconomic factors and other
people have been trying to also to
predict loan repayment or to fight
crimes only using mobile phone metadata
and it's something that extremely new
because now we have the power to use
that sort of very very high-dimensional
data that was not available before but
we have have two issues for researchers
here the first one that is quite
sensitive data I you cannot go to call
your mobile phone provider and say hey
I'm a PhD student or researcher or
practitioner can I access to all data
but all your customer even if you want
animated
and it is really very very difficult to
get that works of data it takes a lot of
time and sometimes they won't give you
the data and that's a good one that it's
even if you read a paper about someone
that say that with an algorithm and how
they use let's see mobile phone meta
data to build features and to predict
something like loan repayment or age of
people it's quite a difficult to like
replicate the results because you don't
know all the all the details of the
implementation are all the features
let's say for machine learning were
computed and you have to guess how they
were made so we designer we we started
to design into bucks three years ago
what he does it basically it takes
thighs for mobile phone metadata which
is called CDR so only loads of
interaction basically one line being a
record with this user called this number
from this cell tower during 30 seconds
and you have also records in a CSV file
and what it does is that it computes a
list of of indicators we have more than
1400 indicators currently things like
entropy as a distribution of your
contacts the radius of gyration so how
much you move every week or every day
and it does that automatically and you
can like give this toolbox a list of a
million of users and it will
automatically compute all the features
for all the user then you can use it for
machine learning after or simply to
analyze your own mobility patterns so
otherwise thing we have around a
thousand and four hundred features
currently in in a few categories of
first basic call n text interactions so
like from very simple stuff like a
number of interactions are too like the
pursuit of conversation that you respond
to also mobility features so indicators
such as the red juice of observation I'm
at you move or things like number of
places that you go number of unique
places and also sometimes you have
access to very very large data sets so
let's say you have thirty percent of the
people in the country all the people are
connected to one mobile phone operator
and in this case we not only have data
about individual people but you also
have links between
see one third of the people in the
country so you can look at things like
clustering coefficient or are such
activity between you either do people
that takes a lot text to people that
also takes a lot and also we work with
mobile phone recharges things like when
people tap at the mobile phone to
analyze like the distribution of
researchers and thing like this so we
tried also to design a work so that it's
very easy that for ninety five percent
of people do the same thing they can do
in a few in a few lives so basically
what you do is that you load the data
back when user some time you want to
visualize the pattern to check if there
are no errors in the data there's a lot
of that as it get out sometime corrupted
or faulty or some things are missing so
you want to visualize quickly how it
looks like and then you want to compute
all the indicators that usually and use
it for machine learning so this is like
a very basic stuff then you can do with
this tool box what you do here that's in
one line you imported the tool Bugs
Bunny good then you read a CSV file
about all the records for one user you
compute all the features one thousand
and four hundred of them and then you
you export them in a JSON file and in
just for them for in just four lines you
have all the features then you can plug
it for instance into any machine
learning to toolbox that you want to use
after and I was saying this is a giant
fine you can you use you can you can get
so you have things like reporting
variables so variables on the quality of
the data sometimes you have like beans
missing data so weeks let's say you have
four weeks where that I was amazing you
would like to check that and you don't
want to look and add the original data
so we have around 40 reporting variables
that we add puts every time and then you
have the list of all the features so
printers hear the response delay for
text messages
um so to load the file we have a
function called read CSV what it does it
basically it's it says that you want to
load fail at the file file a from this
directory of records so you look into
the directory and look for the file
called a dot CSV and then you also loads
a list of locations act location of
antennas and some time i tribute like
gender or age thing like this and the
nice thing about so it's this syntax is
interesting because when you want to
load the network's not only one user but
also that records about all its all its
contacts you will automatically log
learn look in the same directory and
look for file with the name of its
contacts automatically and load them if
they are there and what we do after is
that we not only compute indicators but
we divide them by chang so every week
for instance and we compute the
indicator for them and then we reach an
aggregate of statistics so for instance
if you want to understand the duration
of calls that people make your not only
interested in knowing that the average
duration is 90 seconds you would like to
have a notion of variability of the data
it is the same every week every month
how does it change in the time so what
we do is that we divide every records by
M by weeks so all the call duration
during the first week of the cord
duration during the second one and we
compute things like mean or standard
deviation on that for every week and
then we aggregated so we will compute
the mean of the mean or the curves of
this or the screen s of the main for
every week it gives you a lot of
statistics about a distribution alright
so i will switch to a small network just
to show you how it works in practice yep
yes so if you want to collect data at
your own phone we have an Android app
Advani quit that MIT that if you use /
android actually it doesn't work for
iphone because I apple doesn't let you
download your honor meta data kool
antics you can develop like central
information but not the logs of who you
called with I hmm yeah see we have an
android phone android app or does it
just have one button and you see send
you an email with all your audio records
and you can start your visualizer I'm
analyze them yeah you get a CSV file
with all your records and I also did the
same with Facebook for instance so I
donate all my data from since 2008 all
the texts interaction with people and I
i plug them into bandicoot 2 to analyze
them and i have all the same sort of
metrics and features from so let's say
we have data for users are we're saying
it's csv file with like type of
interaction color color tags direction
the call duration and we can you can
also add data but exact cell tower
location so gps location and when you
load the user so you say you want to
read the CSV about one user called ego
it automatically like describe you
quickly the data so hey you have 300
records from this date to these days you
think that number of calls and you have
tags and gold so like you can read check
if you you made a mistake or not it's
something that we add a couple of months
ago is the visualization to very quickly
visualize the patterns of the data of a
user so when you run visualization that
run it automatically save you over HTTP
a nice visualization so it has like a
list of indicators and the network also
of audio contacts and you can go through
all your indicators and you sho use a
distribution of them either by day of
the week or for all the time range and
you can also so you can do this for you
on that I in two lines of code you don't
know if we found raid then you visualize
them and you can also look at the
subsample of week
almonds depending on what you sayin
because there is a network or so with
how much you you can tag it people in
your network so this is just a sample
user with ABCDE people alright and you
can switch to to our two so two
indicators let's see you look at
initiated interaction or response rate
and you see it interactively whoops yep
alright sorry about that alright so then
what you can do is that otherwise saying
in one line you can compute all the
features but if you want to look into
details you can compute them directly
one by one so for instance we have
featured some indicators in in two
modules individual for individual
features and special for mobility so if
you if you compute for in the percentage
of initiated conversation it returns you
a dictionary with levels of draenor 84
for instance here it tells you that for
all weeks and all all day for taking
into account both call and text you have
thirty two percent of conversations that
were initiated and the same for other
types is the same syntax for number of
antennas you have on average five and
ten as per week register duration is 1.5
kilometers you have all the time you
have the mean is it's on the deviation
of the distribution but if you look at
the signature of when function so let's
say a number of active days you have a
lot of more options that you can
activate you have keywords like group by
interaction samarium so what does that
mean so for instance this is active day
so it tells you that on average you have
5.5 active days per week for all the
weeks of data that you are you notice
that we have a group by our keywords
that you can shine from week two mounts
to known so if you if you paid mountable
divide automatically record by months
and tell you that you have 22 active
days per month on average and if you if
you put it
it will just give you all the it will
take into account the world distribution
so not dividing by weeks and for all the
data you have 44 days with with with
interaction with at least one so this is
the group by keyword we have a sauce
America wars which gives you a control
on the granularity of the statistics
that you compute so for instance if you
look at code duration call duration we
have two types of indicators indicators
like active days I just take a list of
figures and compute the number of active
days or call duration consideration
written a computer call duration for
each record and returns you a
distribution of code duration so either
you have an intake a floating point
number either you have a distribution a
floating point number so in this time is
that this in for this one is a
distribution so you have for every week
of data you have you have the minute
standard deviation and on top of that we
can put them in a solid aviation for all
the week if you want more information
you can you can put a key word summary
extended and it's time you not only have
minutes I'll alleviation but you also
have the courtesy skewness magian min
etc and then you have around more than
12 statistic for a single indicator and
lastly you can also decide you want to
split weekend and weekday weekend and
weekdays are also split day and night
for the same indicator so if we look at
active days you can split them during
weekend and weekday to see if you're
more active during that we can order
into the week day or at night between
that days and you can do the same also
adding some very extended to have
ketosis and skewness unjust and if you
want to export indicators as I was
saying when you have just one function
and you don't need to care about all
that you call the function all and you
say i want an extended summary spitting
day and night and it automatically
compute all the features need to return
a dictionary so with so reporting
variables things like when you load the
data you ignore records because they
were corrupted do you have
were missing missing in the network and
then you have the list of all the other
features etc and then you can export
them in as orange eyes on or CSV if you
want to do this or just use them in your
in your Python code and you export them
to em to a to a CSV file for instance
with a new can export features about one
user objects features about dozens of
users or millions of people so friends
here is a CSV file so you have like one
column bin a single a single features
and then you will have lines about all
your other users all right and lastly
about the code so the things that we try
to make very easy was to extend the
toolbox so that you could like computer
on indicator lets you want to look at
the shortest call every week so just you
you define your function it takes a list
of records and you compute like the call
duration for each one and you compute
the minimum so for every every every
record every list of records you will
written them as a minimum duration
cultivation and what we do let me
develop a simple decorator that I drew
web wraps the gun around the function
and then it says that okay give the
function only call and then / wigs
compute all the statistics and cause a
function for every change and
automatically so we have this function
shoulders call and we when you give it a
user it will just does what we did
before and returns like the statistics
with mean solid aviation if you want to
split by day we'll split by this cause a
function for every day and night average
for every week and computer statistics
so in just a few in just a few lines you
can define your own indicator all right
so back to the initial question so we
are issues with other researchers we had
issues with reflex ability of the data
and pray and privacy issues so
refractive replicability so basically
what we did is design a tool bug that
anyone can use researchers practitioners
and it's very easy to compare the
results that you got because you know
which version you use of the of the tool
box you can cut the version in a paper
if you want to publish it and then
anyone can look at their own data or the
same data sets and computes exactly the
same features so when they do the match
is that when the renton machine learning
algorithms they know that they have
exactly the same features and also
compared to someone that does it on his
own in computerized at 10 or 20 features
we had more than 10 people that work on
the project during three years that did
more than a thousand and four hundred
features so it's a much more robust
project and we also have a coverage
around ninety percent of the code you
think you need test we have regression
tests so that every commits has to
return the same features and before and
also privacy what we do a lot is that
when you talk to a mobile phone provider
that we give them to toolbox they
compute the features they gave us
attributes about people let's say we
want to predict things like social
connect factors to give us the
information they give us the features
but not the individual data and it's
much more easier to give to get that
sort of information that the raw data
and it doesn't leave their servers
alright so during the last week we had a
few partnerships with both universities
and mobile phone providers such as a
round or telenor and I will go through a
few example of country collaboration
that we did in our research labs so the
main question when you have access to
very detailed features about behaviors
of people using in mobile phone that is
what can you do with that can you
predict people behaviors can you predict
gender socioeconomic factors so we had a
study around I within 2013 by colleagues
of mine we try to predict personality of
people basically as I was saying this
for knows a lot about me can it predict
my personality or a little of it
so what we did is that we asked around a
hundred student at MIT we were involved
with the program so that the data was
collected using the mobile phone so we
asked them to fill a survey with a few
dozen questions things like do I see my
team of someone we stole catch Eve do i
do i do things efficiently and based on
that are it they bet on this survey we
can compute a dimension of personality
its concept by a big five indicator list
it computes five dimension of
personality and the research was can we
can we predict the personality of people
based on the features so he was in 2013
and we had a run 36 feature at that part
with bonnie good but they managed to
predict personally personalities of
friends if you look at neuroticism I
basically characteristics like fear
anxiety we can predict up to sixty-three
percent nor decision so if you if you if
you have a value between zero hundred we
divided in low medium and high and you
try to predict the classes based on the
features that we add so we had we have a
baseline of around thirty eight percent
and we go up to a 63 person just by
looking at the features using mobile
phone metadata and again it was a few
years ago we had a run yes sorry sir
teasing features so now we have a bit
more and it was around with 100 students
yes so the questionnaire is a grunters
yeah now it's a standard method to
determine our personality of people it
gives you say give you five dimensions
or neuroticism openness agreeableness
and that was a question here itself yes
that was the Christian here yeah yeah
yeah
I mean as if they were eating thing SVM
for this one yeah basically you have you
had like three or four predictors that
works a lot also for in-store northeast
ISM you have a lot of enough balance
different in balance between women and
men so if you divide if i divide both
you have a lot where why different
values burn then the next question was
can we scale this out so not looking at
100 people but a hundred of thousands of
people what can we predict the badges so
there are many many countries in
especially in the developing world where
you have a very census for instance a
very very old or missing a lot of data
so even simple question like knowing the
gender distribution of people in the
country can be extremely useful so so so
we looked at gender trying to predict
gender of people based on my bites on
data for both European and Asian
countries and again we are we using
using different machine learning
approach we try to predict gender of
people for a run 600,000 people based on
manicured features and we had an
accuracy of around 75 persons by knowing
by training the data to reason with only
five thousand to ten thousand people and
it was for the rural population if you
take on it was a twenty-five percent of
the population you go up to eighty eight
percent accuracy and knowing the gender
of people based only on mobile phone
metadata we give you a very quick and
almost real time if you want information
about distribution of let's say
socioeconomic factors or gender age of
people in countries all right so it's
available on Bonnie put that mit.edu you
can have a look so we work on this since
four years ago we have around 6,000 live
life code with 10 contributors so if you
want to use it if you want to contribute
feel free and so with now's about Python
2 and free
yeah thanks so I did Justin yeah so we
have time for questions so feel free to
ask question yeah yes I have feeling in
the day yeah so basically you can for
instance you CSV so that's what we do
with the Android app so you can get you
on data of the CSV file and easily plug
it but under the hook we have we have
objects or ricotta objects and you can
just use the database and feed it to the
Bandicoot toolbox and just build a list
of records and analyzing directly after
so you can use for the Hadoop cluster
where you have all your data and a nice
body good for individual users yep
understand where did I get the data from
I'm assuming they it's not like so I
have a slide for this one so for the
partnership roof orange they run a
challenge 2 times what they did was
trying to give data so trying to give
CDR data so the logs that orders they
already have inside the company about
meta data that they use for business
football to build people at the end of
the month so they have all the logs of
CD of people meta data and they tried
everything we need to give it to
researchers so that researchers could
work on health care social development
transiently was the last one was in
Senegal so there's a give data 250 teams
of researchers and the research will try
to work with the data so they gave them
mobility datasets and body good features
and researchers had access to this
during I think one year and after the
povitch paper and whatever we're doing
with the data but it's only at animal
data that they are from from from cydia
fights call detail records
yep one of the things you sometimes see
if you're sort of developing acts that
involve a personal data like say for
instance I safety is the difference
between the approaches like Apple
Android terms of what services you might
see Oh certain features are available
android only so it's just wondering you
could kind of offer your perspective on
which approach is better you mean other
company giving the other developer
trying to access the data yeah so so
basically so we we wanted to analyze the
on data so we we started okay we're
gonna do apps for Android and iPhones so
we did an app for Android that you can
download your own data you can also do
it for if you have a studio let's see
with you you make you make an app that
can download the logs of Colin tags for
people you cannot do this with with
Apple say they don't give you access as
a developer to the logs of texts and
calls that you make so it's just
addressing possible with Apple currently
it was it was possible before it's not
anymore i think yeah and also the reason
why we started working in on a very
large LCD our files with that if your
researcher and you want to access that
I've at a lot of people it's kels a lot
when you talk directly to a mobile phone
provider to get the data but all the
other customers in the country and you
directly up the data about all the
customary you don't need to run let's
say to run an experiment and give people
smartphones also if you if you look at
the divided countries in Africa where
you can do a lot of Richard returned she
sprinted for it what's the same forearm
for researchers for in some apt mix or
health care social social good usually
people don't have smartphones and you
don't you cannot install apps on Android
because they don't have android they're
very simple phones so if you want to
to see where the people are going worth
it talking you need to talk to the
mobile phone provided directly let's
respond to what you were
participation but I know that
but you have methods like to get this
data or like yeah so busy we try to make
in very modular so you have functioned
to to group record we have functioned to
/ week bye bye weekend and UK you can do
you can look at ads other at the
underlying function and do what you want
with that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the
road i dunno yeah we try to document
every function so we have an extensive
documentation online it should be a very
documented that sort of yeah yep so you
said that you can work with Danny as a
CSV files like as long as it yes that's
something so you said that you know your
facebook mm-hmm therefore which which
state that you need
computes of these i guess like
so we focus on on on data but
interaction between people so things
like tags that you send to someone or
when you call someone during a certain
number of minutes or seconds and if you
have that out of information is also
mobile phone text message just a chat
application with messages between users
it's a sort of transactional data that
you can plug into man Akutan right you
unloaded for this data just that one
user send a message to this user at that
time or from this place is enough for
for it and you can quickly write a write
something to load the data on in buddy
so so so yeah it's kill actually it's
kel enough so that we can run from
millions of people so when we started
the project actually we we we burn up
with around at the beginning so we
designed the toolbox and work in the
drink a few months then we send them the
code so that they could run as a
production machine and it didn't work it
just like a few days after they sent us
an email like we have a bunch of yours
so we looked into that and actually they
were using a very old version of Python
and they were not using Python so we're
using a Jaden I don't know if people use
here you see item so it's a Python
version interpreted in Java it was a
very old version of giant version 2.3 so
that you could not return dictionaries
from functions everything had to be
sterilized in very simple Python types
as that's why we're so we had to fix
everything and gentrify that's why we
understood that it's actually quite hard
to to make by 10 code for production
machines so we don't rely on things like
numpy if I pandas that could be a bit
faster maybe 10 times faster but if you
do something like this and then you you
want to run it on a production machine
where they don't sometimes I've GCC it's
it's not worse is because you made
something fast that doesn't work in the
production machine so what we do that we
have only patent by 10
so if you want to make it fast you can
probably run it with pie pie with a good
person on jump with when we use bye-bye
but we don't use a things like Mumbai or
of banners and also we don't have
requirements to render tool box you just
take any Python interpreter and render
render codon automatically run
everywhere so it's it's in order of few
hundred milliseconds for people person
so yeah I mean even if you have millions
of people in on under several one takes
less than if you'd like a few thousand
hours yeah 10 hours which is okay when
you use it you when your researcher you
prefer the stuff such words we thought
errors bugs it's what text times when
you develop it and running time is not
that an issue actually we have we have a
sample user for one user but and we we
should have some yeah yeah yeah we're
thinking about adding a a data set about
a few hundred people so that people can
play with it we may have this in the
next weeks and months later I hope so
yeah just very quickly my name is Peter
darling I'm I face have been working
with this experimenting with this
toolbox for a while and I'm working with
the UK you come miss charity for the
Center for sleep and basically gathered
tried to gather
gather statistics on the number is under
locations of the young homeless
population of Britain and they've been
having very little success with
gathering traditional statistics Pacey
gathered by local authorities the
government the onf has recently d
service property search of buyers the
establishment methodology for camp for
rough count rough sleeper tax and we're
basically looking at this type of data
basically to get not just kind of this
some some idea of the street homeless
population through their kind of very
what should be very distinctive movement
social network patterns but also
basically a much more much larger
insecurity house population people are
basically surfing between friends sofas
moving around frequently who aren't kind
of security housed at all and so we're
basically just giving this up you know
we're in a little bit of doing a couple
of seeing whether this is conceptually
possible or not sure if you're
interested in working with us on this
and you'd be very welcome
thanks for that yeah and actually I
think it's the sort of like research
based on mobile phone that is extremely
interesting now because we we have we
can access that of data and for instance
we had colleagues will work with mobile
phone data for millions of people but a
few millions of people and you get a
real-time map of what's happening in the
country people manage to predict very
very like red census map in France in
real time so hour by hour how many
people are in this area of the country
our people are how many people are
moving from this area to this area and
and you can you can do very
groundbreaking research that was not
possible before and even for very small
cities like with you make a habit with a
few hundred people and you have a also
data but people do that about people
behaviors and you can you can do like
studios two pretty people happiness
people personality just based on the
mobile phone something that is not
intrusive at all it just data that is
here available here you can get a
question alright well thanks a lot